you missed it right before I turn on the
camera but do it like this ah cuz I hit
my funny bone and now it still I hate
anatomy hey guys welcome to Tuesday
you're on it's grace let's talk back
Tuesday that was a chihuahua trying to
be a cowboy
I'm working on my impressions let's
start over on Twitter you're here goofs
real McCoy tweets new person first
members and probably they don't know
what a new person comments on any of my
social media platforms I will praise the
crap welcome to the its grace family
hugs feel like Chia Pets fun in theory
just annoying in practice real McCoy
tweets more like the real Macaulay
Culkin's be on Twitter put that on your
to-do list for later
yuuma bread I'm still laughing at grace
Helbig and raging botanist mom's beetle
joke from a year ago that could be
anything my mom makes jokes constantly
she has never memorized anything about
like history or politics but has
memorized like 101 hilarious jokes books
that you find in like the sale section
of a Barnes & Noble God has she molded
me into the person I am today
what did two nuns say when they walk
into a bar two vodka sodas they were
very well adjusted in their worldview
about how they relate to society and
what sort of methods they choose to
relax on days when the Lord just gets
them down
Matthew Darcy's double-o new person to
person to person Matthew Darcy mm more
like Matthew Darcy double Oh
what would I do if I woke up as grace
Helbig asked Tyler anything I'm stealing
Tyler's ask Tyler anything what would he
do if he woke up as me he'd be like oh
this is what this smells like
now it's gonna tell liar
Charcot sexual new person in person in
person Charcot sexual more like yeah
there's probably a subculture for
thinking Chartres
Oh so sexual MTV will probably do it
true life of its in
there's no text on this pose just this
color splash of me and some flowers yeah
pal picked up my heart do better than
person it but I'm not I took my heart
more like no I I am NOT a kleptomaniac
I'm a except a maniac I accept you you
remember the holy traditional observe
beanies Hannah and I wear beanies memory
wears beansie's now the sticky notes
this Lala 96 new person who first movers
in the loft 96 more like you know what
else happened in 1996 let's find out
really quickly
Saudi Arabia France wasn't this year the
Spice Girls released wannabe
international war Oh God
1996 cool year the lightning in the
morning is amazing but have you ever
been lit at night talking about getting
drunk in the darkness
[Music]
brandnew person to person to person
brandy more like the boy's mother shout
out to all those girls that have had wal
share apartments and have had to claim
your territory by screaming through the
wall at each other
yo my boy I wonder what goose smells
like it smell like someone put dust in a
dehydrator that's where you smelling
Kimmy didn't need you're gonna get back
tonight
oh yay look sad if you feel happy nailed
it
okay that's it for talking about to you
guys today I hope that you enjoyed your
time here with me because I you know we
did some interaction and conversation
and that's all that we're really
supposed to do in life I don't know
sign up guys I have to get new passports
I lost mine on account of being an awful
adult and I took my passport photo today
in my camp Takota shirt but they cut it
off because their logos and they put so
much makeup over my Nike forehead tattoo
really unfortunate